ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY.
ARAMBULA BARRICADE HAND BENNETT
BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BURKE CALDERON
RIO CERVANTES CHAU CHEN CHIU
CHOI COOLEY COOPER THANK HIM
DAILY DAILY DAVIES FLORA FONG.
ASIA FREE GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY LACKEY LIII LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN. TWO G.
THE SYRIAN QUINN O'DONNELL
HIRSON PETRI. QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RADIUS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SAY ARTURO SMITH STONE
TíNH RELATIVE ERRORS VEHICLE
WELL VOEPEL. MOST WARD WEB
WICKS WOULD MISTER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER. THE DAYS OF PRAYER WILL
BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN IMAM YASIR KHAN IMAM
YES SIR. IN THE NAME OF GOD.
THE MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST
MERCIFUL. OH GOD. YOUR GRACE
SUSTAINS US THROUGHOUT EVERY
DIFFICULT. AND SUPPLIES ARE
WERE NEEDY HARKS WITH
ENCOURAGEMENT. GIVE US WISDOM
FOR THE WORK THAT IS BEFORE US.
HOME OUR ATTITUDES BLESS US
WITH STRENGTH TO DO THE WORK OF
THIS NEW DAY. I MEAN. THANK YOU
MOM YES SIR WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER FAR
AS HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE
MISTER FALL A MEMBERS PLEASE
WOMEN THE PLEDGE TO PLEDGE I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. TO THE FLAG.
AS. THERE'S A. THANK YOU MAY BE
SEATED. READING OF THE DAY'S
JOURNAL. ASSEMBLY TRIMMER
SACRAMENTO APRIL ONE TWENTY ONE
ASSEMBLY MATTER ONE PM THE
AUDIBLE MULLIN SPEAK APPROACH
THE BECAUSE CHIEF CLERKS YOU DE
RECORD THEY'VE BOWMAN ROLL CALL
THE ROLL CALLED ASSEMBLY WAS
RAY IN THE- AND MISTER FLOOR
SECONDS. THE READING THE
PREVIOUS JOURNAL DISPENSED WITH
PRESS AT BRITISH THERE NONE
INTRODUCTION- REFERENCE OF WILL
BE TO. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE. THERE ARE NONE. WE
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. THE
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY FOR
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ADAM GRAY. TIONAL
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA IN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PHILLIP CHEN.
MOVING TO PROCEDURAL MOTIONS.
MS RADIUS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS TO HAVE
HER AUGHTER SEATED AT HER DESK
TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
CALDERON IS AREA AND MCCARTY
CHOI AND BY THAT IS TO SPEAK ON
AND ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR'S PLEASE
REMOVE THE FOLLOWING ITEMS FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. ITEM ONE
OH SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTY
FLORA. ITEM ONE FOURTEEN AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT- ONE. AND
ITEM ONE FIFTEEN AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN LOW. CLERK WILL NOT.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING CALGARY ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN TWELVE THE MEMBERS A
THIRTY TWO MINUTES NINE FIFTY
NINE THE MINUTES NICE WITH A
MEMBER 634-773-1090
1-112-411-8015 EIGHTY ONE AND
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SIXTY ONE
OF THE MEMBERS. ALL BILLS OF
THE DAY READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED. MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO THE ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE FILE ITEM TWELVE
PASS AND RETAIN. FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN AB TWO SEVENTY TWO BY
MISTER KILEY CORKERY. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO SEVENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KILEY AND
OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
ENROLLMENT AGREEMENTS MR KILEY
EMAIL. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO SEVEN TO
ENSURE THAT A VICTIM OF
CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ASSAULT CAN
PURSUE A CIVIL ACTION AGAINST
THE PERPETRATOR AND OTHER
RELEVANT PARTIES WHAT WE'VE
SEEN IS THAT EITHER HAVE BEEN
TIMES IN CALIFORNIA. WHERE
VICTIMS ARE NOT ABLE TO DO THIS
BECAUSE THE ENROLLMENT
AGREEMENT SIGNED BY THEIR
PARENT- INCLUDED AN ARBITRATION
CLAUSE NOW OF COURSE THERE ARE
MANY REASONS THE CONTRACTING
PARTIES MIGHT. CHOOSE TO AGREE
TO RESOLVE ANY DISPUTES IN ART
IN AN ARBITRAL FORUM- BUT THESE
REASONS ARE NOT APPLICABLE IN
THE CASE OF A VICTIM OF
CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ASSAULT WHO'S
BEING FORCED INTO ARBITRATION.
AGAINST THEIR WILL FOR ONE
THING EDUCATION IS BOTH A RIGHT
AND AN OBLIGATION. UNLIKE
CONTRACTS FOR SERVICES OR OTHER
BUSINESS VENTURES A STUDENT
DOES NOT HAVE THE ABILITY TO
OPT OUT OF THEIR EDUCATION
CALIFORNIA LAW REQUIRES MINERS
TO ATTEND SCHOOL AND OF COURSE
EDUCATION IS CRUCIAL. TO THE
FUTURE SUCCESS SECONDLY
CHILDHOOD SEXUAL ASSAULT IS NOT
A FORESEEABLE CIRCUMSTANCE WHEN
ENROLLING IN SCHOOL AND THIRDLY
CALIFORNIA LAW IS CLEAR ON THE
DIFFERENCE IN TREATMENT
AFFORDED TO MINORS PURTON CASE
LAW ESTABLISHES THAT CLAIMS
HELD BY CHILDREN COULD NOT BE
FORCED INTO ARBITRATION. AND
CHILDREN HAVE THE RIGHT TO
DETERMINE ALL MATTERS THAT
CONCERN THEIR WELFARE
ADDITIONALLY FAMILY CODE SIXTY
SEVEN TEN PROVIDES THE CONTRACT
OF A MINOR MAYBE JUST AFFIRMED
BY THE MINOR THE FEDERAL
ARBITRATION ACT IS NOT SPEAK TO
THE ISSUE OF A PARENTS
CAPACITY. TO CONTRACTUALLY
BINDING MINOR ON THIS ISSUE
THIS BILL PASSED UP THE
ASSEMBLY FOR LAST YEAR WITH NO
AND NO VOTES AND I.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY. THE THING IS KILEY
SAY. NO THIS. OR DEBATE ON THE
MATTER. CARCLUB THE ROLE ALL
MEMBERS. IS OUT OF ALL MAY
VOTER DESIRE. TO ALL MEMBERS OF.
THE DESIRABLE. CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL TELL YOU ABOUT I.
SIXTY NO THE MEASURE. WELL I
FOURTEEN THROUGH FOUR PASS
RETAIN. FOR ME FOURTEEN THREE
THREE PASS AND RETAIN WE ARE AT
FIVE ITEM TWENTY FOUR. BY
MISERY IS AB THREE TWO SEE.
CARBERY ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SIX ASSEMBLYMEMBER LUIS REVERSE
AN ACT RELATING TO HEALTH CARE
MS RIVAS YOU MAY BUT- GOOD
MORNING MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB THREE TWENTY SIX
REMOVES THE SUNSET DATE ON THE
CONSUMER PARTICIPATION PROGRAM
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTH CARE OR DM H. C. D. MHC
REGULATES THE MAJORITY OF
HEALTH COVERAGE POLICIES IN
CALIFORNIA. AND ONE OF THEIR
CORE MISSIONS IS TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS HEALTH CARE. EVERY
YEAR THIS LEGISLATURE
INTRODUCES AN AVERAGE OF FIFTY
BILLS THAT AFFECT THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE TWENTY SIX
MILLION CALIFORNIANS SERVED BY
THE DEPARTMENT. THE CONSUMER
PARTICIPATION PROGRAM WAS
ESTABLISHED IN TWO THOUSAND TWO
TO HELP THE DEPARTMENT FULFILL
THEIR MISSION AND ENSURE
CONSUMERS HAVE A SAY IN THEIR
RECORDS AND MEDICAL DECISIONS.
AFTER ALMOST TWO DECADES IN
EXISTENCE THE CONSUMER PROGRAM
IS NO LONGER NEW AND
EXPERIMENTAL BUT RATHER A WELL
DEMONSTRATED AND SUCCESSFUL
TOOL FOR PROVIDING CONSUMERS AN
IMPORTANT ADVOCATE IN THEIR
CORNER. THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MS RIVAS MR GALLAGHER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL AND I THINK WE SHOULD
THINK ABOUT THIS PROGRAM THAT
WE'VE WE'VE CONSISTENTLY
EXTENDED THE SUNSET. AND THIS
IS REALLY BAD POLICY BECAUSE
WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE ESSENTIALLY
PAYING LOBBYISTS. FOR WORK THAT
THEY DO TO GET A REGULATION PUT
IN PLACE IMAGINE IF WE DID THAT
IN SO MANY OTHER CONTACTS IF A
LOBBYIST SUCCESSFULLY GETS THE
REGULATION THAT THEY DESIRE FOR
THEIR CLIENT. NOT ONLY OTHER
CLIENTS GOING TO PAY THEM. BUT
THE STATE GOVERNMENT IS GOING
TO PAY THEM. FOR BEING CONSUMER
FRIENDLY QUOTE UNQUOTE IN THIS
IN THIS CASE I THINK THAT'S
REALLY BAD POLICY AND SHOULD
NOT BE SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD
BE. APPROVING US AND THIS DID
HAPPEN ACTUALLY RECENTLY D. MHC
PAID TO REGISTERED LOBBYISTS
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE DOLLARS
PER HOUR. FOR THEIR WORK UNDER
THIS PROGRAM WE SHOULD NOT BE
CONDONING THAT NASRI OPPOSITION
TODAY. THANKS GALLAGHER SAYING
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. CARCLUB THE ROLE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. YEAH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE.
THANK WELL CLOSER ALL TIE THAT
ICE FORTY DINOS TWELVE. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS FILE
ITEM TWENTY FIVE. AB FIVE
EIGHTEEN BY MISS WICKS THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
FIVE EIGHTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS AND OTHERS AN ACT
RELATING TO CRIMINAL LAW. THIS
WEEK'S EMAIL OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. EIGHTY FIVE
EIGHTEEN WOULD RESTORE JUDICIAL
DISCRETION IN INSTANCES WHERE
INDIVIDUALS CONVICTED OF
MULTIPLE OFFENSES STEMMING FROM
THE SAME ACT THIS BILL SIMPLY
ALLOWS THE JUDGE TO MAKE THE
BEST SENTENCING DECISIONS GIVEN
ALL THE FACTS IN THE CASE. THIS
BILL DOES NOT CHANGE THE
PROCEDURE FOR SENTENCING A
PERSON FOR DIFFERENT ACTS FOR
EXAMPLE A PERSON COMMITTED
BURGLARY AND THE PROCESS
COMMITTED MURDER THESE TWO
DISTINCT ACTS WOULD STILL BE
SEPT SEPARATELY SENTENCED AB
FIVE EIGHTEEN WOULD NOT APPLY
IN THIS SITUATION. IT IS A
COMMON SENSE BILL THAT- TO THE
TO ALLOW JUDGES MORE
FLEXIBILITY IN TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT ALL THE COUNTS OF THE
CRIME THAT'S COMMITTED IT'S
ALSO A COST SAVING MEASURE IT
WILL SAY THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
MONEY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
WICKS. SEEING THEIR DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE BILL. CLICK WELL
OVER THE ROLE. IT IS OUT OF IT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. FOR ALL MEMBERS OTHERS AT
ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS
REPRESENTATIVE OF.
MISS WICKS
MOVES A CALL. THIS IS AN FILE
OR MEMBERS FILE I'M TWENTY SIX.
MEMBERS. THIS IS FILE ITEM
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY
ONE CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
FIFTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA AN ACT RELATING TO
HEALTH FACILITIES DR ARAMBULA
YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT AB FOUR FIFTY
ONE WHICH WILL REMOVE BARRIERS
IN CURRENT LAW TO ENSURE THAT
AN INDIVIDUAL SEEKING AN
EMERGENCY PSYCHIATRIC CAN
SERVICES HAS TIMELY ACCESS AND
ADDITIONAL CARE THAT MAY BE
NEEDED I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU DR
ARAMBULA MR GALLAGHER OU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER- I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR PEOPLE TO KNOW AND FOR THE
BODY TO KNOW THAT ACTUALLY
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS OPPOSE THIS BILL AT
THIS POINT BECAUSE OF THE
UNEQUAL TREATMENT A
REIMBURSEMENT MANY OF OUR POPS
THAT HELPED MANY PEOPLE IN
MENTAL MENTAL HEALTH
EMERGENCIES. IT IS VERY
DIFFICULT TO RUN THOSE PUFFS
AND THE FINANCING AND FUNDING
THAT COMES IN- IS OFTENTIMES
NOT SUFFICIENT SO YOU'RE GOING
TO BE PUTTING BY PASSING THIS
THE POTENTIAL THAT AND THE AND
THE WARNING FROM OUR ACTUAL
MENTAL HEALTH DIRECTORS IN OUR
COUNTIES IS YOU'RE GOING TO BE
PUTTING THEM IN FINANCIAL
STRESS. AND THAT MAY NOT BE A
VERY GOOD THING IN THE LONG
TERM FOR HOW WE DEAL WITH
MENTAL HEALTH EMERGENCIES WHICH
I THINK WE ALL AGREE WE NEED TO
IN THE STATE SO I WOULD CAUTION
YOU I THINK THERE DO NEED TO BE
CHANGES TO THIS LEGISLATION AS
IT MOVES FORWARD TO ENSURE THAT
THESE ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
OPERATE. THAT ARE PUFFS WHICH
ARE. SUCH VITAL PIECES OF OUR
MENTAL HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
ABLE TO OPERATE. AND NOT FIND
THEMSELVES- UNABLE TO OPERATE.
STABLE IN THE FUTURE SO I'D I
WOULD ASK MEMBERS TO CONSIDER
THAT A BODY UNLESS BILL THANK
YOU. SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM.
DR ARAMBULA YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I JUST WOULD
KINDLY REMIND MY COLLEAGUES
THIS IS A POLICY BILL AND WE
WILL HAVE A CHANCE TO DISCUSS
THE BUDGET IN UPCOMING WEEKS
AND MONTHS AND BELIEVE IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO PASS THIS
LEGISLATION TODAY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. AND WITH THAT
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
SORRY TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF DESIRABLE. TO THE- CLARK
WELL. CLOTHES ARE ALL TIED UP I
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEMS.
TWENTY SEVEN. THROUGH. FORTY
TWO. ASCERTAINED. THAT BRINGS
US TO FILE ITEM FORTY THREE AB
EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT BY MISS
FRIEDMAN CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL
A THIRTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE IN THE
BUILDING STANDARDS THIS
FRIEDMAN YOU MAIL ME THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS HOUSING
AND BUILDING CODES ARE INTENDED
TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE'S
MUNICIPALITIES ACROSS THE STATE
HAVE A LEGAL RESPONSIBILITY TO
BE THE BACKSTOPS TO DO CODE
ENFORCEMENT AND DO INSPECTIONS.
IF THERE'S REASON TO BELIEVE
THAT A BUILDING IS NOT
HABITABLE OR NOT SAFE. HOWEVER
SOME MUNICIPALITIES A VERY FEW
IN THE STATE BUT SOME
MUNICIPALITIES ARE PLACING
PRECONDITIONS. ON A TENANT
BEFORE THEY DO BASIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY INSPECTIONS FOR INSTANCE
BILL MAKE SURE THAT THE TENANT
MAYBE IS CURRENT ON THEIR RENT.
OR MAKE TRIED TO HAVE PROOF
THAT THE TENANT FIRST WENT TO A
LANDLORD A LANDLORD THAT THEY
MIGHT ACTUALLY BE INTIMIDATED
BY OR AFRAID OF. THIS IS A VERY
SIMPLE BILL THAT STATES. THAT A
CITY OR MUNICIPALITY CANNOT PUT
THAT KIND OF PRECONDITION ON
THE TENANT BEFORE THEY DO. THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY INSPECTIONS
FOR WHICH THEY ARE ALREADY
REQUIRED TO DO BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. MEMBERS THIS BILL
WAS SPARKED BY NOT MY READING.
OF VERY DISTURBING STORY IN LA
US ABOUT SOME SLUM TYPE A
UNITS. WHERE BECAUSE THE
TENANTS WERE NOT ABLE TO GET
THE MUNICIPALITY TO DO
INSPECTIONS THEY WERE FORCED TO
LIVE IN SUCH UNSAFE CONDITIONS.
THAT A FIRE ENSUED AND CHILDREN
WERE KILLED. THIS WAS BECAUSE
THE CITY REFUSED TO GO AND
INSPECT ON THE PROPERTY BECAUSE
THE LANDLORD CLAIMED THAT SOME
OF THE TENANTS WERE CURRENT ON
THEIR RENT. MEMBERS EVERY
RENTAL UNIT IN CALIFORNIA
SHOULD BE SAFE FOR ATTENDANCE
IT'S NOT ON THE TENANT TO MAKE
SURE OF THAT IT'S ON THE
LANDLORD I'M INTERESTED HOW
THE- AND THIS BILL JUST MAKE
SURE OF THAT TO PROTECT. SAFETY
AND TO PROTECT PEOPLE'S
PROPERTY WITHOUT AYE URGENT AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER FREEDOM MISTER GALLAGHER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YEAH I THINK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I
URGE MY COLLEAGUES TO THINK
ABOUT SMALL LANDLORDS SMALL MOM
AND POP LANDLORDS WHO. WHO
REALLY JUST NEVER HAVE A VOICE
IN THIS BUILDING SO OFTEN THEY
DON'T HAVE LOBBYISTS. THEY'RE
JUST TRYING THE MOST MANY OF
THEM HAVE THIS AS AN INVESTMENT
IT IS THEIR INCOME. IN THEIR
LATER YEARS OF LIFE BUT NOBODY
EVER REALLY SEEM TO SPEAK FOR
THEM IN THIS BUILDING AND
UNDER. UNDER THIS BILL. SO I'M
GONNA SPEAK FORM. UNDER THIS
BILL. A COUNTY OR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COULD GO OUT TO
INSPECT A PROPERTY BASED ON. AN
ALLEGED VIOLATION AND THEY
COULD FIND NOT THAT THERE WAS
NO VIOLATION WHATSOEVER AND
THAT SMALL LANDLORD WILL GET
LEFT WITH THE COST OF THAT
INSPECTION UNDER THIS BILL. IN
THE CURRENT LANGUAGE. DO YOU
THINK THAT NOW IS A GOOD TIME
TO BE ADDING COSTS EVEN WHEN A
LANDLORD HAS DONE NOTHING
WRONG. TO BE ADDING COSTS AND
REQUIRING. COUNTY CODE
ENFORCEMENT OR COUNTY
INSPECTORS TO GO OUT ON EVERY
SINGLE COMPLAINT- WHEN THOSE
MAY BE UNFOUNDED THERE. THERE'S
ALREADY IN LAW PROCESS FOR
DEALING WITH. WITH LANDLORDS
WHO ARE NOT PROVIDING HABITABLE.
TENDENCIES THERE'S MANY
DIFFERENT PROCESSES FOR PEOPLE
TO TAKE CARE OF THAT ISSUE IN
THE COURTS TO GOVERNMENT-
PROCESS SEES FINES AND
PENALTIES FOR THOSE WHO. WHO
HAVE ACTUALLY. VIOLATED THESE
RULES. BUT TO NOW SAY WE'RE
GOING TO FIND YOU EVEN IF WE
FIND NOTHING WRONG WE'RE GONNA
WE'RE GONNA STICK THE FEE WITH
YOU THE SMALL MOM AND POP
LANDOWNER EVEN IF YOU'VE DONE
NOTHING WRONG WOULD BE A SLAP
IN THE FACE. TO PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL HOUSING WHICH WHICH
THESE PEOPLE DO PROVIDEON A ON
A MASSIVE BASIS IN THE STATE.
AND WHEN THEY HAVE WHEN THEY-
AS OF YET HAVE HAD VERY LITTLE
IN THE WAY OF HELP DURING
COVERED NINETEEN. I REGION OF
VOTE ON THIS ON THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THERE WAS GALLAGHER MR
VOEPEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. I
RISE IN MILD OPERATION TO THIS
BILL NUMBER OPPOSITION HERE'S
WHY I AM A SMALL MOM AND POP
RENTAL PERSON ACTUALLY IT'S
MAINLY RUN BY MOM BECAUSE POPS
UP HERE ALL THE TIME. NOW WHEN
WE RENT OUT A UNIT. WE HAVE TO
SIGN AN AFFIDAVIT THAT SAYS
THERE IS NO LEAD IN THE UNIT.
WHICH MAKES US VERY LIABLE IF
THERE IS ACTUALLY LET SO. MY
MILD OPPOSITION IN THIS BILL IS.
IF THE LAND LORD IS DOING A
PROPER JOB. THEY ARE NOW LIABLE
IF THERE IS LEAD IN THE UNIT
THEY COULD BE SUED. AND
PROBABLY WOULD LOSE IN COURT SO
THAT'S MY POINT SIR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU PAPA. YES NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
MISREADING YOU MAY CLOSE YEAH
THANK YOU I'D LIKE TO JUST
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS
THAT WERE RAISED FIRST OF ALL I
WANT TO SAY THAT WE HVE BEEN
VERY PRODUCTIVE TALKS WITH THE
REALTORS AND WITH THE APARTMENT
OWNERS ASSOCIATION ABOUT THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL WE WILL
CONTINUE TO DO SO. I'M FRANKLY
A LITTLE SHOCKED BY THE
SUGGESTION THAT IF A TENANT HAS
SERIOUS HABITABILITY ISSUES
WITH THE UNIT THAT IF THEY'RE
FACING ISSUES THAT ARE SO
SEVERE THAT THEY LITERALLY
COULD LEAD TO A FIRE COULD LEAD
TO A HEALTH IMPACT OR IF THEY
DON'T HAVE HEAT BUT THEY DON'T
HAVE HOT WATER BUT THEY SHOULD
GO TO THE COURTS AND NOT GO TO
CODE ENFORCEMENT IN THEIR OWN
CITY. RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A
PROCESS IN EVERY SINGLE CITY
THAT YOU ALL REPRESENT WERE
TENANTS THAT ARE FACING THOSE
KINDS OF EMERGENCY NEEDS CAN GO
TO CODE ENFORCEMENT NOW THE
BILL DOES NOT CHANGE WHO PAYS
FOR THAT A CODE ENFORCEMENT
THAT'S DIRECTED BY EVERY CITY
WITHIN THEIR OWN ORDINANCES IN
MANY CITIES THE CITY ACTUALLY
DOES NOT BILL THE LANDLORD IN
MY OWN CITY THE CITIES DON'T
BUILD THE LANDLORDS ARE BILL
DOESN'T CHANGE THAT WE ARE
SILENT ON WHO. IS BILL THAT'S
REALLY UP TO THE INDIVIDUAL
MUNICIPALITIES THE DIFFERENCE
IS THAT WHILE MANY CITIES
PROBABLY MOST OF THE CITIES
THAT YOU ALL REPRESENT A TENANT
CAN GO DIRECTLY TO CODE
ENFORCEMENT THEY HAVE A SERIOUS
PROBLEM THERE ARE A FEW CITIES
THAT SAY THAT TENET NO I DON'T
CARE IF YOU DON'T HAVE HOT
WATER I DON'T CARE IF YOU DON'T
HAVE HEAT I DON'T CARE IF YOU
HAVE MOLD I DON'T CARE IF THE
WINDOWS ARE BROKEN. YOU HAVE TO
PROVE TO ME THAT YOU'VE GONE TO
THE LANDLORD FIRST OR YOU HAVE
TO PROVE TO ME THAT YOUR
CURRENT ON YOUR RENT WHAT THAT
MEANS IS THAT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE TENANTS TENANTS YOU
MIGHT BE UNDOCUMENTED TENANTS
WHO ARE LOW INCOME AND ARE
AFRAID OF ADDICTION DON'T GET
CODE ENFORCEMENT OUT AND ARE
FORCED TO LIVE IN SUBSTANDARD
CONDITIONS. THAT IS THE
POPULATION THAT THIS BILL
ADDRESSES THIS DOES NOT AFFECT
VERY MANY CITIES BECAUSE NOT
MANY CITIES PUT THAT BURDEN ON
TENANTS MOST CITIES DO THAT
CODE ENFORCEMENT WHEN THERE ARE
SERIOUS COMPLAINTS. THIS IDEA
THAT TENANTS ARE GOING TO BE
**** NILLY CALLING CODE
ENFORCEMENT OUT CALLING THEIR
CITIES OUT ON. LANDLORDS IT'S
JUST NOT GROUNDED IN ANY OF
REAL. BUT WHAT DOES HAPPEN. IS
THAT TENANTS WHO ARE POOR.
TENANTS YOU MIGHT BE
UNDOCUMENTED BECOME AFRAID
BECAUSE THEIR LANDLORD SAY. I'M
NOT GONNA DO ANYTHING ABOUT
THIS. AND THEY HAVE NO ONE TO
TURN TO IN THAT CASE. THIS BILL
WAS SPONSORED BY THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY AND
THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION. IT DOES
NOT CHANGE WHO IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR BILLS THAT DOES NOT CHANGE.
PROBABLY MOST OF WHAT HAPPENS
IN YOUR JURISDICTIONS BUT FOR
THOSE FEW TENANTS WHO NEED THIS
HELP THIS IS A DESPERATELY
NEEDED ACTION TO PROTECT HUMAN
SAFETY AND HUMAN HEALTH WITHOUT
AYE URGENT AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
AND WITH THAT THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. ALL MEMBERS. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF.
THE DESERT ABOUT.
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROOM TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY
ONE KNOWS FIFTEEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES. THIS IS FILE ITEM FORTY
FOUR. AB NINE OH THREE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE OH THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER AND
OTHERS NATURALLY IN THE
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS MR FRAZIER
EMAIL ME THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS. AS ±
THE CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
EXPOSED CRITICAL SHORTFALLS AND
HEALTH CARE AND HEALTH SERVICES
FUNDING ACROSS THE STATE.
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR HAVE BEEN
ESPECIALLY IMPACTED BY THE
EMERGENCY. NOW MORE THAN EVER
WE HAVE BEEN WE HAVESEEN THE
LIFE CHANGING IMPACTS OF
DEVOTING EVERY POSSIBLE DOLLAR.
TO SERVING THOSE WE REPRESENT.
EIGHTY NINE OH THREE IS A
DISTRICT BILL TO TAKE STRIDES
TOWARDS ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE.
THE BILL EFFECTIVELY CREATES
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS IN FUNDING FOR BADLY
NEEDED HEALTH CARE SERVICES IN
THE REGION. THE CONTRA COSTA
LASKO. THE CARD FOR CUSTOMER
ORDERS SUPERVISORS. THE GRAND
JURY AND THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION OF APPROVING OF THE
DISSOLUTION. OF THE EXISTING
HEALTH CARE DISTRICT. IN THE
COUNTY ALREADY DESERVES. THE
COMMUNITIES WITH DISTRICTS AND
IN THE BOUNDARIES. THIS
DISSOLUTION WAS PARTLY APPROVED
DUE TO THE JUST RETIRED
MINISTRY OF EXPENSES WITH TOP
SIXTY PERCENT. IN SOME YEARS
COMPATIBLE PROGRAMS AT THE
COUNTY RUN IT 15220% RATHER
THAN LOSE OVER HALF THE FUNDING
TO WASTEFUL ADMINISTRATIVE THIS
EXPENSES AB NINE OH THREE
ENSURES THAT THOSE DOLLARS WILL
BE SPENT PROVIDED NEEDED
SERVICES TO THE COMMUNITY. AS
THEY WERE INTENDED. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER.
MISTER GRAYSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR CHAMBER.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO STAND
WITH MY COLLEAGUES FROM
FAIRFIELD IN SUPPORT OF AB NINE
ZERO THREE THE DISPOSITION OF
THE DISTRICT HAS BEEN A LONG
TERM QUESTION FOR CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY AND THIS BILL IS AN
EQUITABLE SOLUTION. TO THE
HEALTH CARE CHALLENGES FACED BY
THE REGION AS THE COUNTY HAS
NOTICED THE DISSOLUTION OF THE
DISTRICT WILL REDUCE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS AND MAKE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS AVAILABLE FOR
COMMUNITY HEALTH PROGRAMS TO
SERVE OUR CONSTITUENTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU S. GRAYSON SEE
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
ITEM. CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
IS THAT A VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS AT ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS
REPRESENT ABOUT. CLICK WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS I PREPARE TO
LIFT THE CALL. ON THIS WEEK'S
ITEM MISSUS AB FIVE EIGHTEEN
THE CLERK WILL POST. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHICH TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHICH TO VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FORTY ONE KNOWS
TWENTY ONE. THAT MEASURE PASSES
BACK IN FILE ORDER FILE ITEMS
FORTY FIVE THROUGH FIFTY. PASS
AND RETAIN. THIS IS FILE ITEM
FIFTY ONE EIGHTY THREE SEVENTY
NINE BY MR GALLAGHER R. COREY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SEVENTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GALLAGHER AN ACT RELATING TO
CONSERVATION. MR GALLAGHER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB THREE SEVEN NINE
CORRECTS AN OVERSIGHT AND
CALIFORNIA- CODE THAT PREVENTS
THE ACQUISITION OF COUNTY
CONSERVATION LANDS BY
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES CURRENTLY A STATE AGENCY
MAY ONLY SELL CONSERVATION
LANDS TO PUBLIC AGENCIES OR
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS. BUT
SINCE NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES
ARE NOT EXPLICITLY LISTED IN
THE CODE THERE UNABLE TO
PARTICIPATE AS CONSERVATIVES OF
WILDLIFE LANDS. THIS SEEMS VERY
RIDICULOUS SINCE OUR FIRST
PEOPLE ARE SOME IN THIS STATE
ARE SOME OF THE GREATEST.
CONSERVATIONISTS AND KNOW SOME
OF THE GREATEST PRACTICES TO
HELP CONSERVE OUR LANDS AND
THEY SHOULD BE. ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE AND TO ACTUALLY
MANAGE AND OWN CONSERVATION
LANDS- THIS BILL WOULD ADDRESS
THIS PROBLEM BY INCLUDING
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES IN THE LIST OF ENTITIES
THAT CAN RECEIVE CONSERVATION
LANDS AND GRANTS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE. AT THIS BILL WAS
AMENDED AN APPROPRIATIONS TO
ALLOW NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES TO
RECEIVE TO RECEIVE A VARIETY OF
CONSERVATION GRANTS AND VARIOUS
PROGRAMS AS SUGGESTED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THERE
WAS GALLAGHER SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERICAL OF THE ROLE.
RESERVE IT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A. WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
BUT I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEMS FIFTY
TWO THROUGH FIFTY EIGHT PASS
AND RETAIN. THIS IS FILE ITEM.
FIFTY NINE AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
TWO BY MISTER RIVAS CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN TWENTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROBERT
RIVAS AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE IN
THE LAND USE MYSTERY THIS YOU
MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AS WE ALL KNOW TOO WELL
UNFORTUNATELY THAT THERE ARE
MANY FACTORS THAT HAVE
CONTRIBUTED IN. THAT THEY
CONTINUE TO- MAKE WORSE HERE
OUR STATE'S HOUSING CRISIS. AND
AS STATE OFFICIALS AND IS THIS
LEGISLATURE HAVE ATTEMPTED TO
DO MORE IN ADDRESSING THIS
CRISIS. THERE ARE INCREASING
INSTANCES OF LOCAL HOUSING
MEASURES AND REGULATORY SYSTEM
THAT DIRECTLY AND INDIRECTLY.
RESTRICT HOUSING PRODUCTION AND
ARMED CONFLICT WITH STATE
HOUSING LAWS AND REQUIREMENTS
SO CLEARLY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ARE ANY CHALLENGING SITUATION
HAVING TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
BALANCE LOCAL PLANNING AND
REGULATORY HOUSING MEASURES.
AND WORKING TO COMPLY WITH
EVOLVING STATE HOUSING LAW. SO
OFTEN LOCAL OFFICIALS FACE A
CATCH TWENTY TWO GIVEN THAT
EITHER FAILING TO IMPLEMENT
LOCAL HOUSING RELATED MEASURES
OR FAILING TO COMPLY WITH
CERTAIN ASPECTS OF STATE
HOUSING LAW CAN BOTH. RESULT IN
COSTLY LITIGATION. THIS
LEGISLATION THIS BILL CREATES A
PROCESS FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO AVOID THIS CATCH TWENTY TWO
TO SEEK JUDICIAL VALIDATION BUT
A LOCAL MEASURE OR VOTER
INITIATIVE IS IN CONFLICT WITH
STATE HOUSING LAW. CONSISTENT
WITH ESTABLISH STATE VALIDATION
PROCEDURES THIS OPTION FOR
JUDICIAL VALIDATION CREATED BY
THIS BILL WOULD RESULT IN AN
EXPEDITED JUDICIAL RULING ON
THE ISSUE OR QUESTION. OF STATE
AND LOCAL PREEMPTION RELATED TO
HOUSING LAWS AND WOULD PROVIDE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHO CHOOSE TO
USE THIS OPTION OR TOOL WITH
LEGAL CERTAINTY ABOUT THEIR
HOUSING OBLIGATIONS OR
REQUIREMENTS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I VOTE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. THANK YOU MISS
REAVIS. SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE BILL. CLARK WELL
OVER THE ROLE MEMBERS. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. YEAH. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF. CLERK
WILL. CULTURAL TYLER AS FORTY
SIX NO SIXTEEN. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEM SIXTY AND
SIXTY ONE PASS RETAIN. THAT
BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM SIXTY
TWO A. B. EIGHT SIXTY ONE BY
MISTER BENNETT CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT SIXTY ONE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT AND
ACTIVATING A MOBILE HOME PARKS
MISTER BENNETT YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TO INTRODUCE AB
EIGHT SIXTY ONE. THERE ARE A
FEW IMPORTANT POINTS ABOUT AB
SIX EIGHT SIXTY ONE AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND MY SHORT TWO MINUTE
PRESENTATION. THOUSANDS OF
HOMES IN MOBILE HOME PARKS ARE
COVERED BY LOCAL RENT CONTROL
LAWS. THOSE UNITS PROVIDE A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
CALIFORNIANS PARTICULARLY
SENIORS ON FIXED INCOME. WHEN
ONE OF THOSE HOMES IS PURCHASED
BY A PARK OWNER. SHE OR HE IS
TAKING THAT HOME OUT OF THE
LOCAL RENT STABILIZATION
ORDINANCE PROTECTION. AND PARK
OWNERS HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE TO ENGAGE
IN THAT AFTER. THE MOBILE HOME
RESIDENCY LAW WHICH WAS PASSED
BY CALVET THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE IN THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES REQUIRES PARK OWNERS
TO ADHERE TO THE SAME RULES
THAT THEY IMPOSE ON THEIR
RESIDENTS. TODAY RESIDENTS ARE
FORBIDDEN TO RENT OUT THEIR OWN
HOMES AND YET PARK OWNERS ARE
NOT APPLYING THAT LAW TO
THEMSELVES. THIS IS NOT AN
ATTEMPT TO SAY PARK OWNERS
CAN'T ENT THEIR HOMES OUT BUT
THEY CAN'T TREAT THEMSELVES
DIFFERENTLY THAN THEIR
RESIDENTES. END MORE
IMPORTANTLY WHEN THEY WE DON'T
WANT THEM TO HAVE AN INCENTIVE
TO KEEP PURCHASING THESE HOMES
AND PULLING THEM OUT OF LOCAL
RENT STABILIZATION. PARK OWNERS
HAVE CLAIMED THE LAW PASSED IN
THE SEVENTIES REQUIRING THAT
ALL HOMES IN A MOBILE HOME PARK
BE TREATED EQUALLY DOES NOT
APPLY TO THEM. BUT IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN ATTORNEY GENERAL
KAMALA HARRIS RULES THAT IN
FACT IT DOES. THIS ORDINANCE
SIMPLY CLARIFIES AND CODIFIES
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S TWENTY
THIRTEEN OPINION. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER BENNETT. SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ADAM. CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS. THESE ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE START OF A.
ALL MY VOTERS OUT OF.
MISTER
BENNETT MOVES A CALL. FILE ITEM
S. SIXTY THREE THROUGH SIXTY
EIGHT PASS AND RETAIN. THIS IS
FILE ITEM SIXTY NINE AB FORTY
THREE BY MS FRIEDMAN
CORPORATION. ASSEMBLY BILL
FORTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN AND OTHERS AN ACT
RELATING TO TRAFFIC SAFETY. MS
FRIEDMAN YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS
MAKING. LET ME TAKE YOU BACK
AND TELL YOU A LITTLE STORY
FROM MY LOCAL GOVERNMENT DAYS
THE CITY OF BURBANK A FEW YEARS
AGO AND THERE RANCHO AREA WHICH
IS A HORSE OWNED AREA- THEY
HAPPEN TO BE NEAR A COUPLE OF
HIGHWAYS. AND WHEN THE ADVENT
OF APPS TRAFFIC NAVIGATION APPS
POPPED UP MORE MORE PEOPLE WERE
GETTING OFF OF THE HIGHWAY TO
MOVE FOR THIS LITTLE
NEIGHBORHOOD. ARE TO BE TRAFFIC
AND A LOT OF THOSE PEOPLE
WEREN'T FAMILIAR WITH THE AREA
WE'RE IN A HURRY TO GET TO WORK
AND THEY WERE SPEEDING. SO THE
NEIGHBORS IN THE AREA WENT TO
THEIR CITY COUNCIL AND SAID
PLEASE WE NEED SOME TRAFFIC
ENFORCEMENT HERE PEOPLE ARE
SPEEDING IS A ONE LANE ROADS WE
HAVE HORSES WE HAVE KIDS. CAN
YOU PLEASE COME OUT AND GIVE
SOME TICKETS. WELL THE CITY
CAME OUT AND REALIZED I HADN'T
DONE A SPEED SURVEY IN TEN
YEARS AND THEREFORE WERE NOT
ALLOWED TO ENFORCE THE TRAFFIC
RULES. THEY DID THEIR SPEED
SURVEY AND WONDER OF WONDERS
FOUND OUT THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
WERE SPEEDING. BUT BECAUSE OF
THE ARCANE WAYS THAT WE ARE
FORCED TO SAID TRAFFIC LAWS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IN
ORDER TO ENFORCE THE CITY
BURBANK WAS HAD TO RAISE THE
SPEED LIMITS. TO ACCOMMODATE
THE SPEEDING TRAFFIC. THAT IS
ACTUALLY HAPPENS ACROSS OUR
STATE. RECENTLY THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES HAD TO RAISE THE SPEED
LIMITS. ON LITERALLY OVER A
HUNDRED MILES OF ROADS. JUST TO
ENFORCE SPEEDING IN TO TRY TO
STOP SPEEDING AND RECKLESS
DRIVING. SO A FEW YEARS AGO I
WAS ONE OF THE MANY NOT
LEGISLATORS IN THE PAST TO TRY
TO CHANGE THIS LAW. BECAUSE
EVERY YEAR OVER FORTY TWO
THOUSAND AMERICANS ARE KILLED
IN TRAFFIC ACCIDENTS. AND SPEED
IS A CONTRIBUTING FACTOR IN 31%
OF ALL FATAL ACCIDENTS AND ALL
TRAFFIC FATALITIES. WE KNOW
THAT SPEED KILLS AND WE ALSO
KNOW THAT IT WAS EVEN A 5% FOR
A FIVE MILE AN HOUR REDUCTION
IN SPEEDS. LEADS TO ACCIDENTS
THAT ARE MUCH MORE SURVIVABLE.
FOR PEOPLE IN CARS AND PEOPLE
ON THE OUTSIDE OF CARS WHO ARE
HIT. SO A FEW YEARS AGO WE PUT
TOGETHER A VISION OF WHAT WAS
CALLED THE VISION. ZERO TRAFFIC
FATALITY TASK FORCE MADE UP OF
STAKEHOLDERS FROM ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. FROM ALL OF OUR
WALK BIKE GROUPS AND TRAFFIC
SAFETY GROUPS AND THEY CAME UP
AFTER A YEAR OF RIGOROUS WORK
WITH A LIST OF RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND REFORMING THE EIGHTY FIFTH
PERCENTILE IS THAT SPEED LIMIT
SETTING LAW IS CALLED WAS AT
THE VERY TOP OF THEIR LIST.
THIS BILL. IT WAS KEEN WAS BORN
OUT OF CONSENSUS BY MANY
DIFFERENT GROUPS. IT'S A VERY
TARGETED APPROACH LOOKING AT
THE EIGHTY FIFTH PERCENTILE
ONLY. IN A HIGH ACCIDENT
NETWORKS NEAR VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS LIKE SCHOOLS AND
SENIOR CENTERS AND REC CENTERS.
AND WITH AN EYE TOWARDS GIVING
ALL OF OUR JURISDICTION SOME
FLEXIBILITY. AND THEIR CONSTANT
PRESSURE TO HAVE TO RAISE SPEED
LIMITS TO GIVE SOME MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO CAPTURE EVEN
LOWER SPEED LIMITS IN CERTAIN
CASES. WITH AN EYE TOWARDS
PUBLIC SAFETY. WE WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THIS BILL WITH ALL
OF THE STAKEHOLDERS BUT IT'S A
REALLY GOOD PLACE WITH A LOT OF
CONSENSUS AMONG FROM EVEN FROM
GROUPS THAT HAVE NOT SUPPORTED
THESE EFFORTS IN THE PAST. AND
WITHOUT I WOULD HUMBLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISS FRIEDMAN MR FONG. YOUR
RECOMMENDS. I THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER MEMBERS. I RISE IN
SUPPORT TODAY OF AB FORTY
THREE. FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR HER COMMITMENT
TO KEEP. TO KEEPING OUR DRIVERS
PEDESTRIANS AND ROAD SAFETY.
SPEEDING INCREASES THE
FREQUENCY AND SEVERITY OF
VEHICLE CRASHES. AND IT'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR OVER 25% OF
TRAFFIC FATALITIES. SPEEDING
RELATED FATALITIES ARE SURGING
ACROSS THE NATION WITH MORE
THAN SEVENTEEN PEDESTRIAN
STRUCK AND KILLED ON OUR ROADS.
EACH DAY. IN OUR DISTRICTS.
THIS IS A GROWING ISSUE. AB
FORTY THREE. GIVES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THE FLEXIBILITY. TO
SET THEIR OWN SPEED LIMITS
REFLECT THE NEEDS OF DRIVERS
PEDESTRIANS AND BUSINESSES
ALIKE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. ABOUT AN EIGHTY FORTY
THREE. THANK YOU MR FONG. SHINO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
ITEM THIS FRIEDMAN YOU MAY
CLOSE IF YOU WISH I JUST WANT
TO THANK UP MY- CALLING FROM
BAKERSFIELD FOR HIS SUPPORT
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN WITHOUT A
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
AND WITH THAT CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS. DESIRE
TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRABLE. THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ARE ALL TIED UP HIGHS
FIFTY EIGHT THOSE THREE. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEMS
SEVENTY THROUGH. SEVENTY FOUR.
PASS AND RETAIN. BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM SEVENTY FIVE MAYBE
SIX ONE SIX BY MR STONE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SIXTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE AND
OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO LABOR
RELATIONS MR STONE EMAIL THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
SIX ONE SIX SIMPLY ADDS A VOTE
BY MAIL OPTION. TO FARMWORKERS
ELECTIONS RIGHT NOW YOU CAN
THINK OF FORMER COLLECTIONS
ALWAYS BEING HAPPENING AT A
POLLING PLACE WHICH IS NOT
ALWAYS MOST EFFICIENT AS WE
HAVE FOUND OVER THE LAST NUMBER
OF YEARS WHERE THIS BODY HAS
PUT IN PLACE SOME VERY GOOD
OPPORTUNITIES FOR VOTE BY MAIL
THIS WOULD ALLOW SOMEONE TO IF
THEY WANTED TO PICK UP A BALLOT
AND MAIL IT IN. THEIR STILL
SECRET BALLOTS THEY GET SENT
IN. EITHER MAILED INTO THE A RP
OR DROPPED OFF AT AN ARB OFFICE
SO AGAIN SECRET BALLOTS MERELY
PROVIDING A VOTE BY MAIL OPTION
AS WE'VE DONE IN THIS
LEGISLATURE FOR OTHER POLITICAL
ELECTIONS I ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU MR STYLE. MISS
RACE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER. I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONES EIGHTY SIX SIXTEEN WHICH
WOULD MODERNIZE UNION VOTING
I'M A PROUD PRINCIPLE CO AUTHOR
THIS BILL BECAUSE I BELIEVE IN
INCLUSIVITY AND ACCESSIBILITY.
MANY OF YOU KNOW THAT I GREW UP
PICKING ONIONS AND GRAPES. WITH
MY FAMILY AS A YOUNG GIRL.
FARMWORKERS HAVE BEEN CRITICAL
AND ESSENTIAL WORKERS. DURING
THE COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT WE SUPPORT
EFFORTS THAT LEAD TO BETTER
WORKING CONDITIONS FOR THEM.
THIS BILL UP WITH UPLIFT THE
VOICES OF OUR FARMWORKERS
SEEKING TO UNIONIZE BY ALLOWING
THEM TO SEEK MODERN WAYS OF
VOTING A PARTICIPATION. SUCH AS
VOTING BY MAIL. IN UNION
ELECTIONS. WE MUST ENSURE
FARMWORKERS ARE ABLE TO
EFFECTIVELY NEGOTIATE WORKING
CONDITIONS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT YOU JOIN ME IN AND- VOTE
ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU MS
REYES. SEE NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION BANI ADAM. CARPAL OF
NEURAL. PRETTY SAD ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF.
ZERO BURKE WELL. CULTURAL TIE
THE BUT I FORTY FIVE NO
SEVENTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEMS SEVENTY SIX. THROUGH
EIGHTY TWO. PASS AND RETAIN
THIS IS FILE ITEM EIGHTY THREE.
AB TWELVE SIXTY TWO BY MISTER
CUNNINGHAM. ACCORDING ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE SIXTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CUNNINGHAM AND
OTHERS MEDICAL IN THE
INFORMATION PRIVACY ISSUE
CUNNINGHAM EMAIL THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
TWELVE SIXTY TWO ADDRESSES THE
NEED FOR CONSUMER PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS FOR USERS OF SMART
SPEAKER DEVICES THE INNOVATION
OF THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
TECHNOLOGY HAS TRANSFORMED
LIVES THERE ARE OVER TWO
HUNDRED MILLION SMART SPEAKER
DEVICES IN USE TODAY IN THIS
TECHNOLOGY HAS WIDESPREAD USE
IN TREMENDOUS POTENTIAL.
HOWEVER THESE DEVICES ARE
CAPABLE OF RECORDING.
ENTERTAINING IN THE CLOUD
CONVERSATIONS IN YOUR HOME.
THIS POSES A RISK TO OUR
PRIVACY. WHERE THE PRIVACY
INTERESTS IS AT ITS PEAK IN OUR
VERY HOMES OR WE HAVE THE MOST
PERSONAL CONVERSATIONS WE HAVE
IN OUR LIVES WITH FRIENDS
FAMILY AND CHILDREN. AB TWELVE
SIXTY TWO WOULD PROHIBIT A
SMART SPEAKER DEVICE FROM
RETAINER SHARING RECORDINGS OR
TRANSCRIPTIONS THE QUALIFY AS
PERSONAL AND INFORMATION UNDER
THE CCPA. UNLESS THE CONSUMER
HAS OPTED IN AN AFFIRMATIVE WE
GIVEN CONSENT. THIS BILL THUS
FAR HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND HAS HAD ZERO NO
VOTES INTO COMMITTEES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANKS CUNNINGHAM. SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. ON THE
ADAM. CLLR CLUB THE ROLE.
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THAT A VOTE. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE I FIFTY SEVEN
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS EIGHTY FOUR. THROUGH
EIGHTY SIX PASS AND RETAIN.
IT'S FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN AC R.
SIX. BY MISTER SALAS. CORKERY
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS
RELATIVE TO BLUE STAR MOTHERS
OF AMERICA MONTH. MISTER SALAS
ON THE RESOLUTION. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS ACR SIX
RECOGNIZES CONTRIBUTION OF BLUE
STAR MOTHERS IN PROCLAIMS MAY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AS BLUE STAR
MOTHERS OF AMERICA MONTH IN
CALIFORNIA. THE REFERENCE TO
THE BLUE STAR DATES BACK TO
WORLD WAR ONE WHEN MILITARY
FAMILIES WOULD HANG A SERVICE
FLAG IN THEIR WINDOWS A BLUE
STAR DISPLAY FOR EVERY LIVING
FAMILY MEMBER IN THE SERVICE.
BLUE STAR MOTHERS OF AMERICA
ARE THE LARGEST AND FASTEST
GROWING MILITARY FAMILY
ORGANIZATION IN THE COUNTRY
THIS IS FIRED MORE THAN TWENTY
SIX MILLION HOURS OF VOLUNTEER
SERVICE NATIONWIDE. THEY ARE
MOTHERS STEP MOTHERS FOSTER
MOTHERS AND GRANDMOTHERS WHO
SHOWING DURING COMMITMENT AND
COURAGE AND EXEMPLIFY THE BEST
OF AMERICAN VALUES AND
PATRIOTISM. BLUE STAR MOTHERS
CAN BE FOUND TAKING CARE OF OUR
VETERANS CEMETERIES FUNDRAISING
TO SEND CARE PACKAGES TO OUR
TROOPS OVERSEAS ARE DONATING
MONEY TO HELP VETERANS ADOPT
COMPANION DOGS. HAVE BEEN
HONORED TO WORK WITH BLUE STAR
MOTHERS CHAPTERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE TO HONOR RECOGNIZE ACTIVE
DUTY SERVICE MEMBERS. COMING
OFF THE HEELS OF MOTHER'S DAY I
ENCOURAGE ALL OF YOU TO REACH
OUT TO YOUR BLUE STAR MOTHERS
TO RECOGNIZE AND HONOR THEIR
COURAGE. AND DEDICATION TO
PROTECTING THIS COUNTRY.
ACTUALLY ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE
MISTER SPEAKER ENOUGH OF THE
FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS. THANK YOU MISTER SALAS
SEE NOTE DISCUSSION ON THE
RESOLUTION THE AUTHORS ASKING
THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
CRITICAL OF THE ROLE. THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS ON ACR SIX THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS. ON THE
RESOLUTION. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. THE CLERK WILL. CLOSER
ROLE THERE SIXTY FIVE CO
AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY YES
HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. THIS IS FILE ITEM
EIGHTY EIGHT A. C. R. FIFTY
FIVE BY MISTER CHOW FOR CAREER.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FIFTY FIVE FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHAO AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO THE
ONE HUNDRED FIFTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF CHINESE MASSACRE
OF EIGHTEEN SEVENTY ONE. THIS
IS SHALL BE AVAILABLE AND-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS ACR FIFTY FIVE
WE COMMEMORATE OCTOBER TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY TWENTY ONE AS THE
ONE HUNDRED FIFTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE CHINESE
MASSACRE OF EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
ONE. IN OCTOBER EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY ONE IN LOS ANGELES A
FEW BETWEEN LEADERS OF TWO
LOCAL RIVAL ASSOCIATIONS ALSO
KNOWN AS HARP ONE OVER THE
KIDNAPPING OF A YOUNG CHINESE
WOMAN LED TO A SHOOTOUT BETWEEN
SEVERAL CHINESE MEN THAT
ULTIMATELY RESULTED IN THE
WOUNDING OF ONE POLICE OFFICER
AND THE DEATH OF ONE CIVILIAN.
AS A RESULT THIS INCIDENT LED
TO ONE OF THE WORST MASS
LYNCHINGS IN LOS ANGELES
HISTORY A MOB OF ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED PEOPLE REACTED TO THE
DEATH OF THE CIVILIAN BY
ATTACKING AND ROUNDING UP
MEMBERS OF CHINESE POPULATION
TEN LYNCHING DOWN. THE
LYNCHINGS RESULTED IN THE
DEATHS OF EIGHTEEN CHINESE
RESIDENTS OF THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES INCLUDING ONE CHILD WHO
COLLECTIVELY CONSTITUTED 10% OF
THE CHINESE POPULATION AT THE
TIME. IS ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT INCIDENTS OF
RACIALLY MOTIVATED VIOLENCE IN
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY. YES THERE
ARE SIMILARITIES BETWEEN THE
CHINESE MASSACRE OF EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY ONE AND THE ANTI ASIAN
RHETORIC WE ARE SEEING TODAY
THE USE OF THE TERMS CHINESE
VIRUS. AND CON FLEW TO REFER TO
THE COVERT NINETEEN HAS. TRULY
EXACERBATED ANTI ASIAN BIAS AND
DISCRIMINATION. ACCORDING TO
THE STOP API HE COALITION
BETWEEN MARCH TWENTY TWENTY AND
FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THERE WERE NEARLY SEVENTEEN
HUNDRED HATE INCIDENTS
TARGETING API INDIVIDUALS AND-
THESE INCIDENTS INCLUDED TAX
THAT HAVE RESULTED IN SEVERE
INJURY AND DEATH. OF THE
ELDERLY API COMMUNITY MEMBERS
IT IS VITAL THAT FUTURE
GENERATIONS BE REMINDED. ABOUT
THE HORRIBLE HISTORY OF SUCH
RACIALLY MOTIVATED VIOLENT
EVENTS IN ORDER TO REMAIN
VIGILANT AGAINST BIGOTRY AND
HATRED. IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT
FOR US TO ROUTE REJECT HATE
RACISM AND ANTI API BIAS SO WE
MAKE CREATED MORE INCLUSIVE AND
HARMONIOUS SOCIETY IN
CALIFORNIA. AND ACROSS THE
NATION. THE CHINESE MASSACRE OF
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY ONE IS AN
IMPORTANT PART OF LOS ANGELES
IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY. AND IT
IS CRITICAL THAT WE MARKED THE
ONE HUNDRED FIFTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF THIS EVENT BY
PASSING A C. R. FIFTY FIVE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IDOL.
THANK YOU MISTER SHALL. SAYING
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. ON THE
ITEM. MISTER CHOW WOULD YOU
LIKE CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION. MISTER CHOW'S
ASKING THAT THE FIRST WILL BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLL. NUMBERS THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION. NEVER SYSTEMS FOR
CO AUTHORS. CLICK WELL CLOSER
ROLE YOUR SIXTY SEVEN CO
AUTHORS ADDED AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. YES HAVE IT
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. THIS
IS FILE ITEM EIGHTY NINE ACR
SEVENTY FIVE I MISS WALDRON
CORKERY. ASSEMBLY QUICKER
RESOLUTION SEVENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON
RELATIVE TO MATERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH AWARENESS MONTH. MISS
WALDRON YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE ON BEHALF
OF THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS TO PRESENT ACR SEVENTY
FIVE. DEDICATING THE MONTH OF
MAY AS MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH
AWARENESS MONTH. MATERNAL
DEPRESSION IS THE MOST COMMON
COMPLICATION OF PREGNANCY AND
CHILDBIRTH THE WOMEN IN THE
UNITED STATES FACE TODAY. ALL
WOMEN ARE AT RISK OF SUFFERING
FROM MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDERS. SCREENING FOR
MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDERS IS NOT ROUTINE ACROSS
HEALTHSYSTEMS AND EVEN
UNDETECTED ONLY 15% OF WOMEN
ARE TREATED. IT'S ESSENTIAL
THAT WE RECOGNIZE MATERNAL
MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS AND THE
STIGMATIZATION OF THESE
DISORDERS THROUGH EDUCATION AND
ALSO ENCOURAGING WOMEN AND
FAMILIES TO SEEK TREATMENT. I
ASK FOR THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS. THANK YOU MISS
WALDRON. SAYING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE RESOLUTION
MISS WALDRON I'M SORRY.
SMELTERS RECOMMENDS MEMBERS
TODAY RISE IN SUPPORT OF ACR
SEVENTY FIVE I'M A MOM OF A
FOUR YEAR OLDS AND- THIS IS
REALLY TOUGH FOR WOMEN TO TALK
ABOUT. TO TALK ABOUT. THAT TIME
IN YOUR LIFE AFTER YOU GIVE
BIRTH TO A CHILD AND YOU HOLD
THAT LITTLE BABY IN YOUR ARMS
AND IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE GIGGLES
IN TINY TOES AND THE BEST TIME
OF YOUR LIFE AND A NEW
ADVENTURE. YOU HEAR ABOUT HOW
WONDERFUL YOUR LIFE IS AND HOW
LIFE CHANGES WHEN THAT BABY. IS
PLACED IN YOUR ARMS BUT WHAT WE
DON'T TALK ABOUT- THE STRUGGLES
AND THE MENTAL HEALTH STRUGGLES
THAT ALSO OCCURRED. I'M
SOMEBODY WHO HAD SEVERE. MENTAL
HEALTH PROBLEMS AFTER MY
DAUGHTER WAS BORN. THEY DON'T
TELL YOU ABOUT OBSESSIVE
IMAGING THEY DON'T TELL YOU.
ABOUT FEELING LIKE YOU CAN'T DO
THIS JOB. AND YOU DON'T KNOW
WHO TO TALK ABOUT IT WITH YOU
CALL YOUR MOM AND YOUR MOM
TRIES TO BE ENCOURAGING. YOU
CALL YOUR FRIENDS AND THEY
TRIED TO BE ENCOURAGING BUT YOU
FEEL ALONE. AND YOU HAVE A
NEWBORN. A NEWBORN THAT IS
DEPENDING ON YOU TO KEEP THEM
ALIVE TO MEET THEIR NEEDS. AND
IF YOU'RE SO LUCKY TO IDENTIFY.
THAT YOU NEED HELP. AND YOU
REACH OUT FOR HELP. IT'S EVEN
TOUGHER TO FIND THE SERVICES
THE TREATMENTS THAT YOU NEED IS
AN INDIVIDUAL SO YES YOU'RE NOT
ALONE. WOMEN FROM ALL WALKS OF
LIFE EXPERIENCE THIS YES WE
NEED TO RAISE AWARENESS. THERE
IS HELP BUT WE ALSO NEED TO PUT
OUR MONEY WHERE OUR MOUTH IS
AND SUPPORTING WOMEN AND MOMS
BECAUSE THEY NEED ACCESS TO THE
SERVICES. THEY NEED ACCESS TO
THE EXPERTS AND WE CAN DO THAT
HERE SO I STRONGLY URGE FOR
YOUR SUPPORT ON ACR SEVENTY
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU THIS
VALLADARES MR COOLEY. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. BECAUSE I AM PLEASED
TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS I OF
COURSE DO NOT KNOW WHAT IS THE
FIRST HAND OF MATTER. BUT I
REMEMBER THAT DAY THIRTY NINE
YEARS AGO WHEN I CAME HOME FROM
THE CAPITOL TO MY HOUSE. FOR MY
WIFE HAD OUR NEW YOUNG SON. AND
SHE WAS SEATED IN A CHAIR AND
SHE WAS FALLING. VERY UNHAPPY
ANALYTICS SYDNEY WELL WHAT'S
THE MATTER AND SHE HAS ME THE
NEWSPAPER. AND IT IS A THE
COMIC PAGES. THERE ARE SEVERAL
THE COMIC PAGES ARE JUST TOLD
HER WHAT A TERRIBLE MOTHER SHE
WAS. THAT'S ALWAYS STUCK WITH
ME WITNESSES LIKE THERE'S
NOTHING. THAT I COULD SEE THERE
BUT JUST. SHE WAS VERY LOW AND
THE LEAST PROVOCATION JUST
INTENSIFY THOSE FEELINGS OF
SADNESS AND DESPAIR AND BEEN
OVERWHELMED SO I THANK YOU. FOR
BRINGING THIS VIRTUAL. FORTY
THANK YOU MISS COOLEY SEE NO
OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. MISS WALDRON YOU
MAY CLOSE IF YOU WISH THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I URGE AND I
WILL. AND MISS WALDRON IS
ASKING THAT THE FIRST ROLE BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. AS FOR CO AUTHORS. HIS CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION. THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS. THE CLERK
WILL. CLOSE THE ROLE THERE ARE
SEVENTY TWO CO AUTHORS ADDED
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED. AVERAGE THIS IS
FILE ITEM NINETY. ACR ANYONE BY
MISTER QUE HAN CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
EIGHTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PARA QUE HAN AND OTHERS ROSE
WITH A FOOD ALLERGY AWARENESS
WEEK. THIS BARRICADE HANK YOU
MAY OPEN THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS TODAY I STAND TO
PRESENT ACR EIGHTY ONE WHICH
WOULD DECLARE THE WEEK OF MAY
NINTH TO MAY FIFTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AS FOOD ALLERGY
AWARENESS WEEK. CHILDREN AND
ADULTS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA-
FACED WITH LIFE THREATENING
FOOD ALLERGIES. AS MANY AS
THIRTY TWO MILLION AMERICANS
INCLUDING NEARLY SIX MILLION
CHILDREN UNDER THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN HAVE A FOOD ALLERGY.
LIFE THREATENING FOOD ALLERGY
REACTIONS IN THE STATE HAVE
INCREASED BY OVER 3100%
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTING
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN. FOOD
ALLERGIES ARE NOT CURABLE
AWARENESS TO STRICT FOOD
AVOIDANCE AND EPINEPHRINE
ADMINISTRATION IN THE CASE F
ANAPHYLACTIC ARE THE ONLY
TREATMENTS. TWO YEARS AGO I
STOOD ON THIS FLOOR AND YOU ALL
SUPPORTED A BILL THE NATALIE
GEORGIE SUNSHINE ACT IN WHICH
WE WORK TO ENSURE THAT OUR FOOD
WORKERS WERE TRAINED TO HELP
INSURE THAT WHEN CHILDREN AND
THOSE WITH FOOD ALLERGIES DINE
IN RESTAURANTS THEY ARE NOT
UNNECESSARILY EXPOSED TO THESE
DEADLY ALLERGENS. BUT THE WORK
MUST CONTINUE TO PROTECT THE
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
LIVING WITH FOOD ALLERGIES
PUBLIC AWARENESS EDUCATION AND
ACCESS TO THE LIFESAVING
MEDICAL CARE ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL. THIS RESOLUTION IS
SUPPORTED BY NUMBER OF
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING THE
NATALIE GEORGIE SUNSHINE
FOUNDATION THE ASTHMA AND
ALLERGY FOUNDATION OF AMERICA
AND OTHERS. ATHEY PLEASE JOIN
ME IN SUPPORTING THIS WEEK TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE PROTECTING
CALIFORNIANS WHO CAN LOSE THEIR
LIFE TO THESE HORRIBLE
ALLERGIES. THANK YOU IS BETTER
K. HAND MR CHIU YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
ACR. EIGHTY ONE AND I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRING THIS
FOUR AND A HALF- YOU'VE HEARD
THE STATISTICS OF HOW MANY
FOLKS ARE IMPACTED BY THIS.
THIRTY TWO MILLION AMERICANS
ALMOST SIX MILLION CHILDREN
UNDER THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN HAVE
A FOOD ALLERGY AND I KNOW FOR
MANY OF US THIS IS PERSONAL. M.
I WILL TELL YOU THAT BEFORE MY
SON COULD TALK MY WIFE AND I
KNEW THAT HE WAS ALLERGIC TO
NUTS. BUT ONE NIGHT WE HAD A
PASSED A PIZZA. WE DIDN'T THINK
ABOUT THE FACT THAT PESTO
CONTAINS PINE NUTS. HIS FACE
SWELLED UP. HE HAD TROUBLE
BREATHING. FORTUNATELY THE
AMBULANCE CAME ON TIME THE
PARAMEDIC WAS ABLE TO DELIVER
THE LIFESAVING EPINEPHRINE
SHOT. AND WE ALWAYS CARRY AN
EPIPEN. BUT FOR MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS WHO MAY NOT KNOW
ABOUT THIS OR MAY NOT KNOW THAT
THERE'S LIFESAVING MEDICATION.
WE NEED TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO LET FOLKS KNOW. ABOUT ISABEL
ALONG WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR IDOL. THANK YOU MISTER
TO SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION AS PARA QUE
HAN YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU WISH
THANK YOU I JUST WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO
FOR SHARING HIS PERSONAL STORY
AND HIS POINT THIS IS PERSONAL
FOR SO MANY ON THIS FLOOR AND
IN THIS BUILDING AND WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AFTER THE FIRST WILL BE
OPEN FOR COOPER. AND WITH THAT.
WILL OF THE ROLE. THIS IS FOR
HOMEOWNERS THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION. THIS
IS CO AUTHORS. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL
THEIR SEVENTY THREE CO AUTHORS
ADDED WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO SENATE THIRD READING.
THE SENATE THIRD READING PASS
RETAIN A FILE ITEM NINETY ONE
THIS IS FILE ITEM NINETY TWO.
SB. SEVEN CARPOOL RATE. SENATE
BILL SEVEN BY SNATOR ACTIONS
AND OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY OF THE
CLEARING YEARS EITHER OF
SIGNIFICANT MEDIALLY. MYSTERY
THIS YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER ON BEHALF OF
SENATE PRESIDENT PRO TEM ACT IN
SOME PROUD TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL SEVEN A CRITICAL HOUSING
BILL THAT IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
IN ADDRESSING OUR PROFOUND.
HOUSING CRISIS HERE IN THE
STATE CALIFORNIA THE THIS
LEGISLATION AS AN URGENT
MEASURE. TO INCREASE OUR
HOUSING STOCK MIKE STEADY
PROVISIONS OF A SEEK WHAT
STREAMLINING STATUTE. KNOWN AS
AB NINE HUNDRED WHICH REDUCES
PAPERWORK EXPEDITES THE LEGAL
CHALLENGES TO LARGE. MULTI
SOME. THE BENEFIT HOUSING
ENERGY AND MANUFACTURING
PROJECTS NO THIS BILL PROPOSES
TO EXTEND THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
SUNSET OF AB NINE HUNDRED.
THROUGH THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE BUT IT ALSO EXPANDS
THE LAW TO APPLY STREAMLINING
TO MUCH SMALLER HOUSING
PROJECTS LOWERING THE THRESHOLD
OF QUALIFYING PROJECTS TO
FIFTEEN MILLION. THAT'S AN 85%
REDUCTION IN REQUIRED
INVESTMENT OVER THE PRIOR LAW.
UNDER SENATE BILL SEVEN HOUSING
PROJECTS ARE REQUIRED TO HAVE
AT LEAST 15% AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. TO BE INFILL PROJECTS
TO MEET SKILLED AND TRAINED
LABOR REQUIREMENTS AND-
ELEVATED ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDARDS. NOW TO BE CLEAR SB
SEVEN DOES NOT IN ANY MATTER OF
FACT ENVIRONMENTAL MITIGATION
UNDER SEQUEL. NOR THE RIGHTS
OF. THE PETITIONER TO CHALLENGE
IN ADEQUATE ER'S. IT'S SIMPLY
SPEED UP THE JUDICIAL PROCESS
WHERE FEASIBLE. THE TO INSURE
THAT LARGE AND JOB GENERATING
PROJECTS. THAT MEET STATE
PRIORITIES ARE PROVED IN A
TIMELY FASHION AND COLLEAGUES
SB SEVEN THIS BILL IS
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR TO SENATE
BILL NINE NINE FIVE FROM LAST
SESSION LAST YEAR. WHICH PASSED
THE SENATE AND AGAIN IN THIS
HOUSE ON A BIPARTISAN VOTE BUT
UNFORTUNATELY FAILED. WHEN THE
CLOCK RAN OUT AT MIDNIGHT- IN
LAST AUGUST BUT THIS BILL IS A
CRITICAL TOOL IN OUR EFFORTS TO
INCREASE HOUSING OPTIONS.
ACROSS OUR GREAT STATE
CALIFORNIAN WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER. THANK YOU
MISS REAVIS. SANDO DISCUSSION
FOR DEBATE ON THE ITEM. LOVE
THE ROLE MEMBERS. IT IS OUR TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. YOU WANT. ALL MEMBERS OF
YOUR DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL.
CLOSE ROLE AND TELL YOU ABOUT
AYE SEVENTY KNOWS ONE ON THE
URGENCY I SEVENTY KNOWS WINE ON
THE MEASURE THAT SAYS.
NEVER
JUST REPEATING VOTE COUNT ON
PREVIOUS ITEM. I SEVENTY KNOWS
ONE ON THE URGENCY I SEVENTY
KNOWS ONE ON THE MEASURE. THAT
BILL PASSES. AB ONE ITEM ON
CALL A PREPARE TO LIFT THE CALL.
ON MISTER BENNETT'S MEASURE AB
EIGHT SIXTY ONE CLERK WILL
POST. ALL MEMBERS VOTED WHICH
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
WHICH TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL.-KIRKWALL CLOSER ROLE
TELLURIDE'S FORTY ONE. KNOWS
EIGHTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. DOES ANY
MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE AN ITEM
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING HEARING DONE THE CLERK
WILL READ THE SECOND DECK IN
SECULAR. ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
FORTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON AND OTHERS IN A AN ACT
RELATING TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
MEMBERS THIS IS THE CONSENT.
CALENDAR. THIS IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
THIS IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. WELL. CLOSER ALL
TALLY THE VOTE HIGHS SEVENTY
THREE. NO ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED. CALGARY
THE REMAINING ITEMS ON CONSENT
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FOURTEEN I
SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO AND
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY FIVE
SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO. MEMBERS
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED A GERMAN
TO MEMORY MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS. OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR
AT THIS TIME. PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS MEMBERS. PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS MEMBERS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE GREEN
CARPET AT THIS TIME.
FOLLOWING
MEMBERS WERE GRANTED PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MISTER
CALDERON. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF GAIL GARNER ROSKI
A LOS ANGELES BASED ARTIST AND
PHILANTHROPIST THE PASSED AWAY
ON OCTOBER TWENTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY AT THE AGE OF SEVENTY
NINE. IT WAS HARD NOT TO NOTICE
CAL ROSKI WHEN SHE WAS IN THE
ROOM TO THOSE MEETING HER FOR
THE FIRST TIME. HER SMILE PUT
THE MENTEES AND MADE THEM WANT
TO KNOW MORE ABOUT HER. TO OUR
FRIENDS AND FAMILY HER SMILE
WITH HER TRADEMARK. GENUINE
WARM. CARING AND REASSURING.
HER SMILE REFLECTED HER LOVE
FOR HER FAMILY AND HER PASSION
FOR ART AND PHILANTHROPY. BORN
TO WRESTLE TO WHITE AND MARY
LEWIS TUCKER GARNER IN LOS
ANGELES ON OCTOBER ELEVENTH
NINETEEN FORTY FOUR. GAIL WAS
RAISED IN HANCOCK PARK ALONG
WITH THREE OTHER SIBLINGS AFTER
GRADUATING FROM BUCKLEY SCHOOL
GALLON ROLLED IN THE UNIVERSITY
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AS A
FINE ART MAJOR. IT WAS THERE
THAT SHE MET THE LOVE OF HER
LIFE ED ROSKI. HEY MARRIED
AFTER GRADUATION IN NINETEEN
SIXTY TWO AND MOVED TO QUANTICO
VIRGINIA WHERE IT BEGAN HIS
SERVICE TO HIS COUNTRY AS A
MARINE. THE COUPLE RETURNED TO
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN NINETEEN
SIXTY SIX AND SETTLED INTO
LITTLE LAKE. WHERE SHE SET
ASIDE HER PLANS TO BE AN ARTIST
AND FOCUSED ON HER FAMILY AND
RAISING HER CHILDREN. SHE
CHANNELED HER CREATIVE
ABILITIES INTO HELPING WITH
SCHOOL PROJECTS. SEWING
COSTUMES FOR HALLOWEEN AND
SKATING COMPETITIONS
INVOLUNTARY WITH LOSS FOR
FLURRIES DOES TO HELP CHILDREN
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS. AT AGE
FIFTY GAIL WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
CANCER. SHE TURNED TO ART TO
HELP HER IN HER BATTLE WITH
THIS DISEASE AND WHEN SHE
EMERGED CANCER FREE SHE HAD THE
FOCUS RESOLVE. TO PURSUE HER
LIFELONG DREAM TO BE AN ARTIST.
IN THE THREE DECADES FOLLOWING
HER RECOVERY GAIL EXHIBITED IN
MUSEUMS FROM CALIFORNIA TO
SCOTLAND SHE WAS REGULARLY
INVITED ARTIST IN THE ANNUAL
MASTER'S OF THE AMERICAN WEST
ART EXHIBITION AT THE AUTRY
MUSEUM. SHE PARTICIPATED IN
NUMEROUS SEX POSITIONS OF THE
HISTORIC CALIFORNIA ART CLUB
INCLUDING TWENTY INSTALLMENTS
OF THE ORGANIZED. STATION
SIGNATURE EVENT THE GOLD MEDAL
EXHIBITION. GAYLE ALSO SHARED
STORIES OF OTHER CULTURES OF
THE CHILDREN'S BOOK ILLUSTRATOR
DEVELOPING ARTWORK FOR THE
MULTICULTURAL BOOK PUBLISHER
EAST WEST DISCOVERY PRESS. HER
FIRST CAL COLLABORATION WITH
THIS PUBLISHER MAILING IN CHINA
CITY WAS A TRUE STORY SET LOS
ANGELES DURING WORLD WAR TWO
AND RECEIVE NUMEROUS LITERARY
AWARDS. GAIL WAS A DAUGHTER OF
LOS ANGELES NEVER FORGETTING
WHERE SHE WAS FROM HER MOST
SIGNIFICANT BODY OF WORK PAID
TRIBUTE TO HER NATIVE LOGIC LOS
ANGELES. THESE WORKS
COLLECTIVELY TITLED LOS ANGELES
MILLENNIUM SERIES WERE
DEVELOPED OVER TWENTY YEARS
BEGINNING IN TWO THOUSAND. ALL
FORTY FOUR PAINTINGS WHICH
SPOTLIGHTED BELOVED SITES
THROUGHOUT THE SOUTHLAND WILL
BE PUBLISHED LATER THIS YEAR IN
THE BOOK THE GIFT OF LOS
ANGELES. AS A COMMISSIONER FOR
THE LOS ANGELES DEPARTMENT OF
CULTURAL AFFAIRS AND CHAIR OF
ARTS AND FURNISHINGS COMMITTEE
FOR THE CATHEDRAL OF OUR LADY
OF ANGELS. GAIL WAS A STEADFAST
ADVOCATE FOR HER FELLOW ORDERS.
SHE DESIGN ANGEL FORMS THAT
ADORN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
WITH COLORFUL LARGER THAN LIFE
ANGEL STATUES DECORATED BY
LOCAL ARTISTS. FOLLOWING HER
YEARS OF DEVOTION TO ARTS AND
ARTS EDUCATION ADDING GAYLE
ROSKI DONATED IN NAMING GIFT IN
TWO THOUSAND SIX TO THEIR ALMA
MATER. RESULTING IN THE
RENAMING OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA'S OLDEST VISUAL ART
SCHOOL TO THE USC GAIL GARNER
ROSKI SCHOOL OF ART DESIGN.
GILLIS SURVIVED BY HER HUSBAND
OF FIFTY EIGHT YEARS. ED ROSKI
DAUGHTER RAYON ROSKI ST EDWARD
ROSKI THE THIRD AND HIS WIFE
CALLING RUSTY. DAUGHTER KATRINA
ROSKI AND HER HUSBAND MIKE
PEARL AND SEVERAL GRANDCHILDREN.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON MR
THIS YEAR AND YOU ARE ALSO
RECOGNIZED ON THIS ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM WHITTIER FOR HER
VERY ELOQUENT AND COMPASSIONATE
WORDS ABOUT A CONSTITUENT WHO-
DID SO MUCH FOR LOS ANGELES-
GAIL. WITH A LOS ANGELES BASED
ARTIST AND PHILANTHROPIST. WHO
LIVED INTO LOCAL LAKE SINCE
NINETEEN SIXTY SIX. AS SHE
PASSED PEACEFULLY SURROUNDED BY
FAMILY AND HER VIBRANT
WATERCOLOR PAINTINGS THAT
BROUGHT SO MUCH JOY TO SO MANY
PEOPLE. GAIL WAS SUFFERING FROM
ALS SHE WAS THE LOVING WIFE OF
REAL ESTATE DEVELOPER ED ROSKI
AND THE MOTHER OF THREE. GALA
ATTENDED USC WHERE SHE ALSO MET
ED. GAIL USED ART AS A PART OF
THERAPY TO BATTLE THE HORRIFIC
DISEASE. SHE LETTER IT LATER
EMERGED CANCER CANCER FREE. I
HAD THE FOCUS AND RESOLVE TO
PURSUE HER LIFELONG DREAM TO BE
AN ARTIST. MANY OF HER VIBRANT
WATERCOLOR PAINTINGS DEPICTED
THE LIFE AND LAND OF CULTURES
AROUND THE WORLD. SHE WAS AN
AVID WORLD TRAVELER. GAYLE ALSO
SHARED STORIES OF OTHER
CULTURES AS A CHILDREN'S BOOK
ILLUSTRATOR. DEVELOPING ARTWORK
FOR THE MULTICULTURAL BOOK
PUBLISHER EAST WEST DISCOVERY
PRESS. SHE WAS ACTIVELY
INVOLVED WITH PUBLIC ART
INITIATIVES AS A COMMISSIONER
FOR THE LOS ANGELES DEPARTMENT
OF CULTURAL AFFAIRS. AND THE
CHAIR OF THE ARTS AND
FURNISHING COMMITTEE FOR THE
CATHEDRAL OF OUR LADY OF ANGELS.
FOLLOWING HER YEARS OF DEVOTION
TO ARTS AND EDUCATION IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX AND GAIL PLEDGED.
A NAMING GIVE TO THEIR ALMA
MATER WHICH RESULTED IN THE
RENAMING OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA'S OLDEST VISUAL ARTS
SCHOOL. AT THE USC GAIL GARDNER
ROSKI SCHOOL OF ARTS AND DESIGN.
WEATHER WAS OVERCOMING HER
CATARACT FOR CANCER. OR HER
FIGHT WITH ALS GAIL LEARN FROM
EACH EXPERIENCE AND USE THESE
CHALLENGES TO OVERCOME THEIR
HARSH REALITIES AND PROVIDE A
HOLISTIC SUPPORT FOR OTHERS WHO
WOULD BE CHALLENGED BY THE.
SAME DIFFICULTIES SHE HAD TO
OVERCOME. HE WILL BE MISSED MY
THOUGHTS ARE WITH. ED PATRICIA
RAN KATRINA AND EDWARD THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER. THANK YOU
MISTER NAZARIAN. MR MCCARTY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE WILD FOR
YOUR ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY
I ASK THAT WE ADJOURN AND HONOR
THE LIFE OF OUR ROW HAAS THE
SACRAMENTO IN FROM MY DISTRICT.
WHOSE COMMITMENT PASSION AND
CARE FOR OTHERS THAT WAS DEEPLY
FELT BY OUR COMMUNITY PASSED
AWAY RECENTLY AT THE AGE OF
EIGHTY TWO WE'RE JOINED HERE
TODAY BY HIS FAMILY IN THE
GALLERY. HE WAS A LARGE AND
INFLUENTIAL PRESIDENT PRESENCE
IN OUR COMMUNITY ESPECIALLY
WITH ORGANIZATIONS THAT HE
VOLUNTEERED WITH LACCOLITH VETS
FOR PEACE DSA BROWN TO RAISE
THE NATIONAL LAWYERS GUILD. HE
WAS A LIVING LEGEND FOR
PROGRESSIVES HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. HE LED WITH
FEARLESSNESS AND HIS ALWAYS HAD
THE SENSE TO SPEAK TRUTH TO
POWER PEOPLE AT CITY HALL RIGHT
HERE AT OUR STATE CAPITOL. HE
ATTENDED PROTESTS AND COMMUNITY
EVENTS FOR ALL KINDS OF CAUSES
FOR LIVING WAGES FOR WORKERS
FOR POLICE REFORM TO
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES LIKE THE
KEYSTONE PIPELINE IN STANDING
ROCK. HOW HE WORKED IN THE
SHADOWS OF TITAN TITAN LABOR
ORGANIZERS HE WORKED WITH OUR
LEGENDARY LABOR LEADER ASSESSOR%
CHAVEZ AND HELPED HELPED FOUND
THE UNITED FARM WORKERS DECADES
AGO. HE WAS SAT WITH HIS FAMILY
YOU ARE HERE WITH US TODAY THE
PITTSBURGH AND WESTERN
PENNSYLVANIA TO ORGANIZE FOR
FARMWORKERS RIGHTS THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES AND SEVENTIES DECADES
LATER HE WAS SEEN AROUND THE
COMMUNITY HERE IN SACRAMENTO
FIGHTING FOR THE SAME RIGHTS
WORKING FOR. MAKING SURE WE
PRIDE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
JUSTICE TO DRISKELL FOR THEIR
WORKING CONDITIONS. FOR THE
WORKERS IN THE SALINAS VALLEY- STATE LABOR
COMMISSIONER. AND AGAIN HE WAS
A FOUNDER OF ORGANIZATIONS THAT
CHAMPION HUMAN RIGHTS IN THE
NORTH AMERICA'S AND AS WELL AS
DEMOCRACY IN MEXICO. HE SERVED
AS THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
SACRAMENTO CHAPTER FOR THE
LABOR COUNCIL FOR LATIN
AMERICAN ADVANCEMENT LACKLAND.
NO MATTER WHAT HE WAS ORGANIZED
DURING. HER PROTESTING IN THE
COMMUNITY HE WAS ALWAYS PASSING
ON HIS. HIS KNOWLEDGE. HIS
ENERGY AND HIS PASSION TO THE
NEXT GENERATION HE MENTORED
MANY. AND HE HAS SOME OF THOSE-
FOLLOWING IN HIS FOOTSTEPS HERE
TODAY. HE WAS A FEARLESS WITH
LOTS OF ENERGY INTO ITS FINAL
DAYS- HE'S REMEMBERED HERE WITH
A GREAT SOME BOROUGH WALKING
AROUND SACRAMENTO WHETHER IT
WAS THE WINTER. OR A HUNDRED
DEGREES THAT WAS HIS STAPLE.
HIS LOSSES FELL HEAVILY IN OUR
COMMUNITY WHERE HE WAS A
CORNERSTONE ELDER WITH
TREMENDOUS HISTORICAL KNOWLEDGE
ON THE SOCIAL MOVEMENTS THAT HE
WAS PART OF. AGAIN PLEASE JOIN
ME IN A JOINING HIS MEMORY
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. THANK
YOU MR MCCARTY. AND DOCTOR CHOI
YOU ARE NOW RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY THANK YOU
SPEAKER AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
LIKE TO ASK A WE ARE JOHN
TODAY'S A SESSION IN MEMORY OF
DAVID THE CAR WASH EMAIL DAVID
COME COERCION MY WAS SUCH A
LONG TIME PHOTOGRAPHER AND A
FRIEND OF INDIA SIXTY EIGHTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT. ON APR
EIGHTEENTH OF THIS YEAR DAVID
THE WAS SO TRAGICALLY KILLED IN
A CAR ACCIDENT DAVID AROSE OUT
OF THE LONG TIME CITY OF IRVINE
PHOTOGRAPHER AND A FRIEND OF
TOO MANY IN THAT REGION DAVID
OF COURSE SONOMA IS SO REMEMBER
TO FOR HIS- EXCELLENT ABILITY
TO CAPTURE MILESTONES
THROUGHOUT THE. SIXTY EIGHT THE
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT RIGHT I WAS
SOME ARE- I GOT TO KNOW DAVID
THE VERY WELL. HE ALWAYS HAD A
SMILE ON HIS FACE AND THE
CAMERA IN HAND AND THE WAS SO
EAGER AND EXCITED TO CAPTURE
MEMORIES SO IN IRVINE SO
HISTORY. ROB THE EATERS THIS
CITY MILESTONES RANGE OF THE
FROM CELEBRATIONS MEETINGS
EVENTS PRESENTATIONS AND SO
MUCH MORE DAVID THE COLISEUM
COLISEUM A WAS SUCH A FOR. A
PHOTOGRAPHY EXPERT AND THE
BROUGHT ALL THE BEST IN PEOPLE
AT THE MEETINGS AND EVENTS
DAVID WAS SUCH A FIXTURE IN THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AREA AND
THE WAS SO WELL KNOWN FOR HIS
EXPERTISE AND APPELLANT TO IN
PHOTOGRAPHY. DAVID WAS BORN IN.
NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT HE WORKED
AYE S. OF PHOTOGRAPHER FOR MANY
YEARS OWNING HIS OWN
PHOTOGRAPHY BUSINESS- FOR OVER
THIRTY THREE YEARS FROM
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT. THROUGH. TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE. HE WAS ALSO A
FREELANCE PHOTOGRAPHER. AND-
FREELANCED FOR TERM MEDIA FROM.
THOUSAND EIGHT AS WELL A SELF
FOR THE LOS ANGELES TIMES OF
FROM. NINETEEN NINETY THREE
THROUGH TWO THOUSAND FOUR DAVID
CAUTION AMONG WAS EDUCATED AT
UCLA HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS SO
LONG TIMES BALLS OF A TWENTY
NINE YEAR OR SO JOPLIN MICK
LORE. AS WELL- SO HIS OF STEP
CHILDREN LOUISA AND IRENE DAVID
IS SO ALSO SURVIVED BY HIS TO
SISTER SO SOME CAUTION MARC AND
HIS A BROTHER TONY COSCIA WHO
WAS SO FORMALLY A MALE OF A
CITY OF A CUSTOM. DAVID WAS
ALWAYS A FAULT FOR KIND AND THE
DEDICATED HELLO SILVA DAVID
COSTUMER IS DEVASTATING TO OUR
COMMUNITY AND TO THOSE SO WHO
KNEW AND LOVED HIM I EXTEND MY
DEEPEST CONDOLENCES OF THE
DAVIS FAMILY FRIENDS AND THE
ALL OF THOSE SO. WHO KNEW DAVID
WELL. I WE SAW THE LIFE OF THE-
KALASHI MAR AND THE A OR HER OF
OUT TO HIS FELLOW. AT THIS
ALMOST A DIFFICULT TIME WE WILL
ALWAYS REMEMBER DAVID COLE
SHIMMER AND THE MEMORIES SO HE
GIFTED COSTA WITH. WE WILL
DEEPLY MISTER DAVID AND THE
ORDER NEVER FORGET IS A SMILING
FACE IS A PASSION FOR
PHOTOGRAPHY AND THE
HISTOLOGICAL FOR HAS A
COMMUNITY FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DETROIT.
AN ASSEMBLY WOMAN CALAVERAS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
IN MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO
HONOR THE LIFE OF AN AMERICAN
HERO. SERGEANT FIRST CLASS
DONALD CASE STRICKLAND WHO
WOULD OFTEN SAY THAT HIS AND I
QUOTE PROUDEST ACCOMPLISHMENT
WAS DEFENDING OUR GREAT NATION.
AS A YOUNG BOY DONALD AND HIS
FAMILY CAME TO CALIFORNIA IN
NINETEEN THIRTY SEVEN IN SEARCH
OF A BETTER LIFE. LIKE MANY DID
BACK IN THOSE DAYS. HE GREW UP
IN THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY AND
WHILE ATTENDING HIGH SCHOOL ON
HIS SEVENTEENTH BIRTHDAY DONALD
JOINED THE NAVY. HIS FATHER HAD
TO SIGN PAPERS IN ORDER TO
RELEASE HIM TO ENLIST IN THE
KOREAN WAR. WHILE IN KOREA HE
SERVED ON THE FAMED AIRCRAFT
CARRIERS. THE USS YORKTOWN AND
THE USS HORNET. AFTER THE
KOREAN WAR AND THREE YEARS AND
THE NAVAL SERVICE HE DECIDED
THAT THE ARMY WAS WHERE HE
REALLY WANTED TO SERVE AND
WHERE HE SPENT THE NEXT
EIGHTEEN YEARS OF HIS MILITARY
SERVICE. DONALD IS BASIC
TRAINING AT FORT BOARD FORT
BRAGG NORTH CAROLINA AND JOIN
THE LEGENDARY EIGHTY SECOND
AIRBORNE. DURING HIS FIRST JOB
AFTER TRAINING DONALD.
PARACHUTE FAILED TO OPEN
THANKFULLY IT OPENED JUST IN
TIME TO AVOID HITTING THE
GROUND. HE MAKE LIGHT OF HIS
NEAR DEATH EXPERIENCE AND SAY.
I WAS THE LAST ONE OUT OF THE
PLANE AND THE FIRST ONE DOWN.
WHILE STATIONED IN WEST GERMANY
DONALD MET AND MARRIED THE LOVE
OF HIS LIFE ANTONIA BRONZE.
DONALD SERVED TWO TOURS OF DUTY
IN VIETNAM AND WAS AWARDED THE
BRONZE STAR FOR BRAVERY IN
ACTION DURING THE TET OFFENSIVE.
DONALD RETIRED FROM THE ARMED
SERVICES IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE BUT RETIREMENT DIDN'T
SUIT HIM WELL. HE WORKED AT THE
SIMI VALLEY POLICE DEPARTMENT
AND BECAME A MANAGER AT
CONVALESCENT HOSPITALS
THROUGHOUT MENTOR ACCOUNTING.
HE DIDN'T ACTUALLY END UP
RETIRING UNTIL THE AGE OF
SEVENTY FIVE. DONNA IS SURVIVED
BY HIS WIFE OF SIXTY YEARS.
ANTONIA HIS CHILDREN GABRIEL
RENE AND THE HONORABLE TONY
STRICKLAND. HIS GRANDCHILDREN
JACOB SYMANTEC NATASHA
ALEXANDRIA RUBY AND TONY AND
HIS GREAT GRANDCHILDREN WHY IT
KAYLA SOPHIA AND RICE. MEMBERS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF THE FULL
AND BEAUTIFUL LIFE OF SERGEANT
FIRST CLASS DONALD CASE
STRICKLAND. THANK YOU MICHELLE
THERE'S. MEMBERS PLEASE BRING
THE NAMES OF THE DESI PRINT IN
THE JOURNAL REQUEST RICHARD A
MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
ANNOUNCEMENTS WISHING ALL
MOTHERS A HAPPY BELATED
MOTHER'S DAY AND I UNDERSTAND
TODAY. IS MOTHER'S DAY LINE
AMERICA. SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS TUESDAY MAY ELEVEN
CHECK IN SESSION WEDNESDAY MAY
TWELFTH CHECKING SESSION
THURSDAY MAYTHIRTEENTH FOR
SESSION IS AT NINE AM ALL OTHER
ITEMS EMAINING WILL BE PASSED
RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUE. SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER MERCER SHE MOVES AND
MISS WALDRON SECONDS. THAT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL-THURSDAY MAY THIRTEENTH AT NINE
AM AND THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED.
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO
I TO NOT VOTING.
ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO- TO
NOT VOTING.